five years now without a decisive game
in the classical portion in those five
years there has been a huge influx of
new chess fans who may not understand or
appreciate why we have so many draws
could you have a comment or way of
explanation of why we see so many roles
Well normally uh
you need
mistakes for a decisive result so
probably
tell you that players are not making too
many mistakes yeah and you play
consistently yes you don't wander too
often at least yeah in general chance
becomes quite a drawish game
um
yeah I would say that so much has been
has been written and said about this I
really don't have have a lot a lot to
add
we try
well we are happy that you do thank you
very much